these steps are all that's left of a
family home that had stood for nearly 80
years
the water Rose so quickly that people
here say they barely had time to escape
[Music]
sought shelter at a relief center but
had to move again when even that was
flooded
she returned home as soon as the waters
receded
not much can be salvaged
I don't have the words to describe how I
felt when I first saw the damage it is
so sad nothing this bad has ever
happened to us my house and everything
in it was swept away just like that
many say these floods are the worst in
living memory
Greek structures fared much better this
house is still standing even though it
was almost completely submerged in flood
waters now if you take a look at the
wall behind me flood waters left a brown
stain and that gives you an indication
of just how high the waters reached
heavy rains last weekend caused this
River to burst its banks
even homes on Higher Ground have not
been spared
around 3 A.M The Rains in the river were
very loud I looked out my window and saw
a part of the hillside had collapsed
then I heard another sound it was only
in the morning that I discovered my
son's house had collapsed
he's worried his house could be next
some authorities say the climate crisis
has played a role in the severity of
floods
the one indication of that is a very
unprecedented levels of rain high levels
of rainfall huge that combined with our
deforestation of ours our forest
together with a lack of increase or in
the upgrade of drainage and irrigation
flooding is common in Malaysia during
the monsoon season although it varies in
severity
but without a long-term mitigation plan
people here will have to keep rebuilding
their lives and their homes year after
year
Florence Louis Al Jazeera basude
tranganu State Malaysia